very nice guy in good family man and
then they find it as a youth that you
stole things and I find that very hard
to believe you just do not seem what the
kind of guy that would steal III think I
know what you're talking about I didn't
see it as theft it felt like an unspoken
agreement okay why don't you explain you
guys when I first started out in the
show bidness mm-hmm I was in my early
20s and my wife and I married 25 years
by the way I tell people it feels like
it's only been ten minutes
yeah underwater
[Laughter]
joke joke a doctor told me well yeah
yeah I said I'll use that so here's the
deal when I we lived in a apartment in
New York we had a shower in our kitchen
we were broke right and then I would get
thank God I get these lovely jobs where
you go out and do a movie or a
television thing and they fly your first
class and they put you up in these
lovely hotels and it was wonderful and
then you order and you feel like you're
living large and then you order room
service and it's like 50 bucks from an
omelet hey take it easy yeah by the way
that's not what you're supposed to do
the omelet for 50 bucks you do what you
want there on the road your loan big you
know you're a penny just I just felt
like there's no way they the the
silverware must have been included
there's the way I looked at know how
could it not be what are you paying for
otherwise yeah so I felt better
bye we could take the silverware home
yeah see that seems reasonable right
have you spayed of these there's no way
the eggs those are just eggs yeah eggs
and it's a coffee store $1 it must
include the silverware take the cart
yeah yeah I try to stay with the carry
on yeah yeah right so travel light so I
used to our silverware collection when
we were starting out was all civil we're
from hotels and and they're great
they're really nice stuff and so people
would come over and they'd be like oh I
love the fork here and I'd be like
that's it's from the standard spoons
from the Waldorf
so that's that's very nice I think you
did the right thing it is it is crazy it
is crazy when you when you're traveling
and you look at the bill it's crazy and
by the way here's the cool thing there
no one will ever call you on it the
hotel's never gonna be like excuse me
mr. Oliphant we're missing the fork and
a knife no no so that's why you know
it's ok I have a question ok they say
some they would say something yeah I'm
sorry but you can't take it somewhere
yeah yeah but they don't do take the
rope do you ever take the road because a
lot of times I seem about to take the
robe and then it has a sign on it that
says if you'd like one of these robes
you may consult the front desk that's
the suggestion you don't go but Andy do
you take the robe ever no I've never
taken that I've never taken the robe
because I'm afraid they'll charge me and
it'll be like a hundred bucks yeah for a
stupid robe yeah you know right hold on
a second though are you a robe guys you
like how you wear a robe I would take
the robe I don't do you were I don't
really enjoy the road I don't wear a
rope every time I've gotten a robe the
next thing I'd turn around my wife's
wearing it he's like thanks for the robe
I'm like I thought it was my robe but
yeah anyway then you realize she's just
stealing silverware with it yeah
you